diesen augenblicken beginnt im petersdom
die liturgie des aschermittwochs der
übertragen wir jetzt live den gesamten
gottesdienst und er wird kommentiert von
christian horner von der deutschen
bischofskonferenz
der aschermittwoch ist für gewöhnlich
der tag an dem die kardinäle zusammen
mit dem papst in santa sabina auf dem
argentinien rom die heilige messe
begehen
es ist eine ungewöhnliche situation in
diesem jahr und auf grund der erwarteten
menge der gläubigen
diese heilige messe zelebriert im
petersdom den papst ging voraus die
kardinäle
denn die türkische dienst trägt die
violette farbe es ist die farbe der buße
die an diesem aschermittwoch über die
gesamten 40 tage der fastenzeit hin
angelegt werden
die 40 tage der fastenzeit sollen
hinführen durch gebet buse persönliches
sich zurücknehmen
zum osterfest zum credo um zu den
heiligen drei österlichen tagen von
leiden tod der grabesruhe und der
auferstehung jesu christi
der papst schreitet durch die vater des
petersdoms
die station gottesdienst ist der
terminus technicus wird vor den toren
des petersdoms beginnen
[Musik]
audi benninger konditor nostra spaces
komplette bus sa grad in abstinenz jahr
fuß aus quadraten aria der schöpfer mit
den gesang wir rufen 40 tage lang
in dieser heiligen fastenzeit dich an
zur buß und reu bereit
[Musik]
zum schluss eines jeden windows steht
das lob der heiligsten dreifaltigkeit
glückselige dreifaltigkeit ganz 1 in
einer wesenheit gibt gnade dass die
fastenzeit den deinen gute frucht
verleiht
[Musik]
9o battle badete viele das spielhaus
vaters des sohnes und des heiligen des
neubaus auch eine tiefe erneuerung des
geistes verbunden sei durch christus
unseren herrn
[Musik]
es folgt die anrufung des herrn mit dem
kurier christe eleison als einleitung
der allerheiligenlitanei
[Musik]
in der allerheiligen litanei wendet sich
die kirche und die heiligen die seligen
an die engel bittet um fürsprache um
beistand
[Musik]
die heiligen werden in verschiedenen
gruppen gerufen
zunächst wird die mutter gottes beistand
gebeten
sondern die heiligen dinge danach die
patriarchen des alten landes die apostel
und evangelisten dann auch die märtyrer
[Musik]
die kirchenväter und die kirchen werden
sollte
[Musik]
heiliger benedictus bitte für uns so
wurde soeben gebetet
der heilige benedikt der vater des
westlichen mönchtums der auf ältere
grundlagen basieren die regular sagte
benedikt seinen ordensregel
zusammengefasst hat mit der herr
zugleich den grundstein für das mönchtum
für das mönchische leben
[Musik]
im gesamten land gelegt hat der heilige
benedikt ein europäischer heiliger der
heilige den sich der papst zum patron
gewählt hat
[Musik]
der zweite teil der allerheiligen die
tonalität über den die anrufungen die
christus gebühren christus der sohn des
lebendigen gottes erbarme dich unser
christus der duh in die welt gekommen
bist
er war wirklich eine so christus der
gekreuzigt worden ist erbarme dich unser
[Musik]
ähnlich wie es beim rosenkranz davon ist
so werden auch hier bei den anrufen und
christi
im einzelnen heißt haben christie die
stationen des heils wirkens des erlösers
nachgezeichnet
in christus in erinnerung an die
einzelnen heißt warten mehr bahnen
gebeten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach der station nach diesem innehalten
nach der sammlung vor der eigentlichen
vor dem eigentlichen beginn der heiligen
messe sind die schule jetzt den
introitus fans dieser wert ist um jung
domina du herkommst ich alle herr und
hass nachsicht mit den sünden der
menschen damit sie sich bekehren
denn du bist der herr unser gott
[Musik]
euro
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit dem altkirchlichen kür ihren ruf für
ils und christa lesern für leser
begrüßt das feiern der gottesvolk den
herren designer mitte das bitte um
erbarmen und anerkennt dass christus der
herr ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
region osteuropa konzentrieren poker
christiana die initiale controller
konzern vertrauen natürlich beginnen
wird die 40 ganz die kraft zu
christlicher zug kommt damit für den
bösen absaugen
man hat entschieden hat das gute tun mit
ihr lebt und herrscht von ewigkeit zu
ewigkeit
so spricht der herr kehrt und mir von
ganzem herzen mit weinen und klagen
erreicht ihre herzen nicht eure kleider
sieht um zum herrn eurem gott wenn er es
gnädig und barmherzig langmütig und
reich an güte und es freut ihn dass das
unheil verhängt hat vielleicht geht er
um und es freut und erlässt segen zurück
sodass ihr speise und trank opfer
darbringen könnt für den herrn euren
gott auf dem zion stößt in das horn und
ein heiliges fassen im ruft einen
gottesdienst aus versammelt das volk
heilig die gemeinde versammelt die alten
holt die kinder zu sagen auch die
säuglinge der bräutigam verlassen seine
kammer und die braut ihr gemacht
zwischen vorhalle und altar sollen die
priester klagen die diener des herren
sollen sprechen hat mitleid herr mit
deinem freund und überlasst ein erbe
nicht erstanden
damit die völker nicht über uns spotten
warum soll man bei den völkern wagen wo
ist denn ihr gott da erwachte im herren
die leidenschaft für sein land und er
hatte erbarmen mit seinem volk
[Musik]
es folgt der antworten auf die lesung
mccarthy erbarme dich unser denn wir
haben gesündigt
aus dem 20
sich
[Musik]
payback karten
ist es
wie tissot liebe kammerchor am 11
[Musik]
du hättest für die todeszahlen
viele die zu johannes foto zu tun dass
viele praktische motor führen
[Musik]
es folgt die zweite lesung aus dem
neutestamentlichen buch aus dem brief
des apostel paulus an die korinther aus
dem zweiten brief des heiligen paulus an
die korinther brüder und schwester wir
sind also gesandte an christi statt
und gott ist es der durch uns mahnt wir
bitten an christi statt
lasst euch mit gott versöhnen er hasst
den der keine sünde kranke für uns zur
sünde gemacht damit wir in ihm
gerechtigkeit gottes würden als
mitarbeiter gottes ermahnen für euch
dass er seine gnade nicht vergebens
empfangt denn es heißt zur zeit der
gnade
er höre ich dich am tag der rettung
helfe ich dir jetzt ist sie da die zeit
der gnade
jetzt ist er da der tag der rettung
[Musik]
lob der christus könig und erlösung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ihr heute seine stimme wird
verzerrt wird nicht euer herz so sind
sozusagen die schule der chor die
gemeinde antwortet lob der christus
könig der ewigen herrlichkeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in der feierlichen prozession in der der
diakon das evangeliar das buch das die
evangelien enthält je familien stellen
die der heiligen messe gelesen werden
verkündet werden
diese prozessoren wird christus geehrt
der in seinem wort zu entsprechen wird
[Musik]
domino bis matthäus dem matthäus
evangelium
[Musik]
die nazis zu seinen bietet euch eine
gerechtigkeit vor der die menschen zur
schau zu stellen sonst habt ihr keinen
lohn von eurem vater im himmel zu
erwarten wenn du almosen liebst lass es
also nicht vor der herr posaune sowie es
die heuchler in den synagogen und aus
den gassen tun
von den leuten gelobt zu werden
amen das sage ich euch
sie haben ihren lohn bereit erhalten
wenn du almosen liebst so soll deine
hand deine linke hand nicht wissen was
seine rechte tut
ein almosen soll verborgen bleiben
und dein vater der auch das verborgene
sieht wird es dir vergelten
wenn ihr betet macht es nicht viele
heuchler
sie stellen sich beim gebet gern in
synagogen und an die straßenecke damit
sie von den leuten gesehen werden
[Musik]
amen das sage ich euch
sie haben ihren lohn bereits erhalten
du aber gehe in deine kammer wenn du
bist und schließt die tür zu
dann beteten vater der im verborgenen
ist dein vater der auftrags verborgene
sind wird es der vergelten
[Musik]
wenn ihr fastet macht kein finsteres
gesicht wie die heuchler sie gegen sich
ein tragfähiges aussehen damit die leute
merken dass sie fasten amen das sage ich
euch
sie haben ihren lohn bereits behalten
du aber salbe dein haar wenn du fassen
und wasche dein gesicht dein haar
wörtlich deinen kopf damit die leute
nicht merken dass du fastest sondern nur
dein vater der auch das verborgen sieht
und dein vater der das verborgene wies
wird es dir vergelten
[Musik]
nach dem evangelium folgt die familie
die predigt des heiligen vaters
[Musik]
wenn der atv at le carré hat elisabeth
merk oder die männer brüder und liebe
brüder und schwestern heute antwort wie
können wir einen neuen posten zeitlichen
wege ein weg der sich über 40 tage
erstreckt und zur freude war dass ostern
des herrn zum sieg des lebens mit den
tod führt nach der alten römischen
tradition der fastenden seitlichen
endstation ist haben wir uns zur feier
der eucharistie versammelt diese
tradition sind vor dass die erste starts
die ja basilika santa sabina auf dem arm
die umstände uns nahegelegt die vatikan
basilika zu wählen
[Musik]
wir haben uns heute abend zu vielen um
das grab des heiligen des apostels
petrus versammelt um in diesen
besonderen augenblick seine fürsprache
für den weg der kirche zu erbitten und
unseren glauben an den obersten gärten
christus den herrn zu erneuern
für mich ist dies eine günstige
gelegenheit während ich mich an
schüttelt in petrus teams zu beenden
allen und insbesondere den gläubigen der
diözese rom zu danken und um ein
besonderes gedenken im gebet zu bitten
die lesungen die wir gehört haben geben
uns anregungen die wir dazu sind wir
berufen
mit gottes gnade in dieser fastenzeit zu
konkreten einstellungen und
verhaltensweisen werden vor allem ruft
uns die kirche den kraftvollen april ins
gedächtnis denn der prophet duell an den
an das volk israel richtet spruch des
herrn erklärt um zu mir von ganzem
herzen mit fasten beinen und glauben
der ausdruck von ganzem herzen ist
hervorzuheben dass der bitte unsere
gedanken und gefühle heraus von den
wurzeln unserer entscheidungen
anschlüsse und horten her in einer
haltung völliger und radikaler freiheit
aber ist diese umkehr zu gott überhaupt
möglich weil es eine kraft gibt die
nicht in unserem herzen wohnt sondern im
herzen gottes selbst stimmt das ist die
kraft der barmherzigkeit der prophet
sagt weiter kehrt um zum herrn eurem
gott denn er ist gnädig und barmherzig
und reich an güte und es freut ihn dass
er das unheil verhängt die umkehr zum
herrn ist als gnade weil sie werk gottes
und frucht des glaubens ist den wir
wieder neue in seinen worten setzen
doch dieses umkehren zu gott wird nur
dann in unserem leben konkrete
wirklichkeit wenn die karte des fern
es erschüttert und uns die kraft gibt
unsere herzen zu zerreißen
denn auch diese worte spricht punkt
durch den propheten zerreißt eure herzen
nicht eure kleider auch in unseren tagen
nämlich sind viele bereit angesichts von
skandalen und ungerechtigkeiten die
natürlich immer die anderen begehen ihre
kleider zu zerreißen aber nur wenige
scheinen bereit
nach ihrem eigenen herzens in ihrem
eigenen gewissen und ihren eigenen
absichten zu handeln und zu zulassen
dass der herr umformt jenes kehrten zu
mir von ganzem herzen ist ferner ein
aufruf der nicht nur den einzelnen
sondern die gemeinschaft betrifft
ebenfalls in der ersten lesung haben wir
die worte gehört auf dem see um stößt
indes worden ordnet ein heiliges osten
ruft einen gottesdienst versammelt das
volk heilig die gemeinde versammelt die
alt holt die kinder zusammen auch die
säuglinge
der bräutigam verlassen seine kammer und
die braut die gemeinschaftliche
dimension ist ein wesentlicher
bestandteil des christlichen glaubens
und legen
christus ist gekommen die versprechen
kinder gottes wieder zusammen
das wie hier der kirche ist die
gemeinschaft in der jesus uns zusammen
der glaube ist notwendig kirchlich es
ist wichtig dass wir uns in dieser
zweiter fast zwei daran erinnern und
dies auch leben
jedem soll bewusst sein dass er sich
nicht alleine auf den weg der börse
macht sondern gemeinsam mit vielen
brüdern und schwestern in der kirche
schließlich verwaltet der prophet beim
gebet der priester die sich mit tränen
in den augen am code wenden und sagen
überlasten er wäre nicht der schande
damit die völker nicht über uns sputen
warum soll man bei den völkern sorgen wo
ist denn hier gott dieses gebet lässt
uns darüber nachdenken wie wichtig das
christliche glauben zeugnis und leben
eines jeden von uns und unsere
gemeinschaften ist um das antlitz der
kirche sichtbar werden zu lassen und wie
sehr dieses anliegens fußball einstellt
wird
ich denke insbesondere an die sünden in
die einheit der kirche und die
spaltungen im kirchlichen leben
individualisten und rivalitäten zu
überwinden
und so die fastenzeit in einer innigeren
und greifbaren kirchlichen gemeinschaft
zu leben ist ein demütiges und kostbares
zeichen für die die den glauben fern
sind oder ihm gleichgültig
gegenüberstehen
jetzt ist sie da die zeit der gnade
jetzt ist er da der tag der rettung die
worte des apostels paulus an die
christen von korinth erklingen auch für
uns mit einer dringlichkeit die keine
untätigkeit oder trägheit zuletzt das
wort jetzt dass er mehrfach wiederholt
bedeutet dass man sich diesen moment
nicht entgehen lassen darf wird uns als
einzigartige und um wiederholbare
gelegenheit angebot und der blick des
apostels konzentriert sich auf die
gemeinsamkeit mit der christus seine
existenz hat gar aktualisieren wollen
als er alles menschliche und sogar die
sünde der menschen auf sich nahm
hierfür findet der heilige paulus starke
worte gott hat ihn für uns zur sünde
gemacht
jesus der unschuldige der heilige der
der keine sünde kannte nimmt die last
und auch die konsequenz der sünde
aufsicht geteilt den tod mit der
menschheit den tod am kreuz die
versöhnung die uns geschenkt wird hat
einen denkbar hohen preis gehabt dass
auf golgotha errichtete kreuz an dem der
mensch gewordene sohn gottes gehangen
hat dieses eintauchen gottes das
menschliche leid und in den abgrund des
bösen dass die wurzeln unserer gericht
machen
umkehr zu gott mit ganzem herzen führt
auf unsere kosten zeitlichen weg durch
das kreuz durch die nachfolge christi
auf jener straße die zum kalvarienberg
zufällig selbst im gau geführt
es ist ein weg auf dem wir tag für tag
lernen immer weiter aus uns heraus zu
gehen unseren egoismus und unserer
verschlossenheit und gott raum zu geben
der das herz aufschließen verwandeln und
der heilige paulus erinnert uns daran
dass die botschaften kreuz ins dank der
bändigung des wortes dessen herold der
apostel selber ist eine erinnerung für
uns damit dieser fassen zeitliche weg
davon gekennzeichnet sein möge dass wir
wieder aufmerksamer und beharrlicher auf
das wort gottes hören das licht dass
unsere schritte erhält des sogenannten
bezieht sich jesus auf drei grundlegende
praktiker die das moralische gesetz
vorsieht gebet anfassen
die sind auch die traditionellen
einladung von ganzem herzen zu rundherum
zu klären
doch jesus unterstreicht dass es die
qualität und die wahrheit der beziehung
zu gott ist in die echt halten jeder
religiösen geste ausmacht deshalb
bräuchten das verhalten was gesehen
werden die haltungen die nach beifall
und billigen nicht sich selbst sondern
sein vermeidung großzügig
und zwar unser zeug wirkungsvoller sein
je weniger auf unserem eigenen leben und
uns wird betont das gericht das 1 1 mit
auf dem weg des am ende des tages
zufrieden
in dem nicht mehr begegnen mit ihm von
angesicht beginnen wir zuversichtlich
und freudig umfasst zeitlichen der
aufruf zur umkehr soldaten unser
schollen der augen wird von ganzem
herzen zu kehren
die seite genau dazu die uns zu neuen
menschen die teilhabe am leben jesus
selbst möge daher niemand von uns diesen
aufruf überhören der auch im strengen so
schlicht zugleich so viel sagenden ritus
des aschenkreuzes zugleich vollziehen
werden
möge uns in dieser zeit die jungfrau
maria begleiten
die mutter der kirche und das vorbild
jedes echten jüngers des herrn
heilige vater hat in seiner predigt in
seiner schrift auslegung die
bedeutsamkeit der persönlichen umkehr
hervorgehoben
der umkehr zu christus
christus der der weg die wahrheit und
das leben ist
wer bei der auferstehung christi
ankommen möchte wer teilhaben will am
leben in gott muss seine sein herz nicht
seine kleider zu reißen so der
eindringliche appell des heiligen vaters
als zeichen dieser busse werden den
gläubigen wird den gläubigen nun
gesegnet heraus aufgelegt im zeichen des
form des kreuzes zuvor wird diese asche
gesegnet
k
liebe brüder und schwestern wir wollen
gott unseren vater bitten dass er diese
asche segne die wir als zeichen der buße
empfangen
gut du wirst nicht den tod des sünders
du willst dass er sich bekehrt und lebt
in höhere gnädig unsere bittner segne
diese masche mit der wir uns bezeichnen
lassen weil wir wissen dass wir staub
sind und zum staub zurückkehren
hilf uns die 40 tage der user in rechter
gesinnung zu begehen
verzeihung unsere sünden erneuerte uns
nach dem bild eines sohnes und schenke
uns durch seine auferstehung das
unvergängliche leben
darum bieten wir doch in christus
unseren herrn
der heilige vater beschränkt besprengt
mit weihwasser die asche und segnet
sowieso mit
bedenke mensch dass du staub bist und
wieder zum staub zurückkehren wirst
bekehrt euch und glaubt an das
evangelium
[Musik]
so spricht der priester
wenn er in form des kreuzes die
aussegnung
auf das haupt trägt
[Musik]
diese asche wurde gewonnen aus dem
gesegneten palmzweigen des vorjahres so
ist es brauch der kirche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
euro
[Musik]
[Applaus]
höhere herr und habe borman denn wir
haben nicht vor dir
so sang der chor
es folgt nun die fürbitten die
moderationen wersal ist das allgemeine
gebet der gläubigen
plagiate patienten misericordia so lasst
uns beten zu gott dem vater der geduldig
und barmherzig ist was er zu hören uns
rufen wir bitten dich liebe den glauben
der kirche wie hüte unseren papst
benedikt höchste alle die verfolgung
leiden
[Musik]
er leuchtet die theologen leiten die in
der wissenschaft tätig sind ermutige die
zweifelnden vergibt die sünder hirsch
und schenke den versorgt und neu gekauft
[Musik]
das pendel oder dusche den kosten
gewalttätigen kommt enormen zu helfen
was die konten deiner nähe spüren
[Musik]
das neue heilige erstellen
er weckt die sehnsucht nach der liebe
sind deiner gegenwart
die profitänzer quary sie mal renovierer
titelaspirant in der caritas oder kita
nati lucia grazer per christus zu
senioren
mit dem allgemeinen gebet der gläubigen
kommt die liturgie des wortes in der
heiligen messe zu ihrem ende zu einem
abschluss die liturgie der eucharistie
beginnt mit der bereitung der opfer
lagen die schule sind ich will dich
rühmen
denn du hast mich aus der tiefe gezogen
und lässt meine freude um lässt meine
feinde nicht über mich triumphieren
herr mein gott ich habe zu viel
geschrien und du hast mich wie ein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
heuer ist das große dankgebet der kirche
[Musik]
und vollzieht sich auf wirkliche
idealerweise
das österliche geheimnis
der tod christi am kreuz das kreuz und
auferstehung juristischen opfer und
jesus christus war auf gegenwärtig in
dem der priester die worte der
konsekration der wandlung spricht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
während im himmlischen vater gebracht
damit dass sie wandeln mögen
leib und das blut unseres herrn unseres
christus
[Musik]
der ritus der gabenbereitung der
vorbereitung der ort vergraben
es begleitet von vielen gebeten an den
vater an den himmlischen vater
[Musik]
zugleich sind die gläubigen aufgefordert
gewesen herz mit auf den altar zu legen
und dem vater umzubringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
negativ fiel mir was ich hier gerade die
opa eine potente bietet brüder und
schwestern das meiner und eurer opfer
konnte man sich den vater gefordert
wir haben dass ein fahrer aus deinen
händen zum rundum seines namens für uns
und seine ganze unser gott zu beginn der
heiligen 40 tage bringen wir dieses
quartal und bitten dich hilfen zu kehren
und taten der buße und der liebe zu
vollbringen
damit wir unseren bösen neigungen nicht
nachgeben
einige uns von sünden und machen uns
fähig das gedächtnis des lions unseres
herrn jesus christus mit konzernen
da
[Musik]
graziös agamus domino die austria
wäre die videos mp3 geradeaus aber in
wahrheit ist der heilige vater
allmächtiger ewiger gott zu danken
durch das fasten des leibes hältst du
die sünder nidda der hebst du dein geist
gibst du uns kraft und den sieg an jesus
christus durch ihn loben die ich mit
einer erhabenen größe bete dich an die
mächtige wollte die himmel die
himmlischen kräfte und die selige
serafin feiern sich jugendchor mit ihnen
das auch unsere stimmen sich vereine und
voll ehrfurcht rufen
[Musik]
unheilig
das ist eigentlich als und
journalistische hochgefühl und im kombi
darin und esens oder so nicht wer hat
sie munter verraten noch mit mona lisa
kategorie muss zudem spiritualität eris
und corpus sozusagen island viele täter
- die jesus christus mandaten ist jeder
cd brahms sehen im inferno petra debatte
activity vegas als benedix siegfried die
die kritische politische aktivität
mandate exorcist ihn im korpus leon-rot
provobis tradition
[Musik]
semi modehaus communote miss kardashian
integrationspolitik sieht die die
politische aktivität pptx ihr oben es
hieß es in karlsruhe
nur wer die therme testamente die
provisorische von dieter der emissionen
pk tourenwagen-wm kombinationen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mysterium wie die
[Musik]
viele touristische passion ist lektor
mirabilis resektion zeta-jones in jedem
set presto land des alterns advent und
affäre musste migrations referenten
rucksack delitzsch und über mit
soundcheck lesung uns in operationen weg
gewesen to the new orleans ostia
progression ist immer dass sie ohne
plakat konzentriert wie corporate sagen
sie natürlich immer spielte sascha
riether ein kompositum spiritus in
weniger haben in christa lieb sein aus
die wirklich hat modus hat korrekt ist
durch die tat dem konzert wie wollen
muss im primus conwert ist immer wieder
diverse elektrische maria hubert des
apostolischen gloriose materie was
gewusst hat ist euromint rezessionen
pedro apotheke und videos hat die wahren
kosten ostrale konzipiert ist professor
- nun die partie markus luthe der krise
antoine berlin an dem intern viele
qualität der firma generisch konform
europa nostra benedetto compiz kobinet
universität am nico polo akquisition ist
wo die schulfamilie von tv-star ivo luis
di resta profitiert eines videos sowie
kaspersky wie clemens barth - community
frau chris moss tor von torsten spd
prozent des solls ökologisierung ihn
ringend und berlin mitte die foris
beratungs und simon gloria tour
parameter der christen dominum nostrum
weil bewohner
und ja solar
[Musik]
durch ihn und mit ihm unternehmen dass
dirk ein richtiger vater in der einheit
des heiligen geistes
eine herrliche fällt er jetzt und in
ewigkeit
[Musik]
ja
lieberose senior ict maria consilia zu
lösen ein richtiger vater von hast du
dich mit einem abo
wir brauchen uns vor verwirrung und
sünde und damit wir voll zuversicht dass
ovations erwarten
[Musik]
senior associate editor posten wie la
toya tito lamy apache von barbarino die
partie weil er fädelte natürlich ist die
turnhalle juni tatsächlich konjunktur
wohl unter zugewinne sehqualität sekunde
passe der senior ist ja sein konvoi
der friede christi der fall trage
ausgeht
der vom lösungs wirken christi ausgeht
die nur christus selbst geben kann
diesen frieden und bietet der heilige
vater den konzelebranten
und im ganzen feiern volk gottes
[Musik]
christus
gib uns deinen frieden ich bin nicht
würde ich das du ein gehst und da meint
auch aber spricht nur ein wort so wird
meine seele gesund selig die zum
hochzeitsmahl des nutzers geladen sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gemeinschaft gemeinschaft jesu christi
deshalb muss die gemeinschaft des
hauptes mit seinen kindern
[Musik]
geht ihnen alle welt und verkündet das
evangelium
[Musik]
alle menschen sind gerufen
diesem leib der kirche anzugehören
[Musik]
christus wirft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der mtv die die schüler zur auszahlung
einige sind
[Musik]
ist aus dem ersten zahlen genommen und
da heißt
wer über die weisung des herrn nach sind
beitragen acht grenzen flucht zur
rechten zeit
[Musik]
o
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jesus spricht wer mein fleisch ist und
mein blut trinkt hat das ewige leben und
ich werde ihnen auf erwecken am letzten
tag denn man fleisch ist wirklich eine
speise und mein blut ist wirklich ein
trank wie mein fleisch ist und mein blut
trinkt der bleibt in mir und ich bleibe
ihm
[Musik]
wer aber dieses brot ist wird leben in
ewigkeit
[Musik]
o
marl eib bossert die jungfrau uns gebaut
du hast unsere schuld gebüßt sterbend
auf dem kreuzer alltag
[Musik]
moskau
blut und wasser sind geflossen
[Musik]
wir streiten uns hoffen in der todes not
gefahr
[Musik]
es müssen jesus
oliven der jesus
[Musik]
und jesus fusion mariens
denn von der heiligen kommunion und die
darauffolgende stille zur sammlung
werden abgeschlossen durch ein gebet
register sacramento barmherzige gott ist
stärke uns durch dieses heilige mahl
damit verfassten können wie es dir
gefällt und durch die feier dieser tage
heilung finden bieten wir durch christus
unseren herrn
der kardinal staatssekretär tarcisio
bertone wendet sich an den heiligen
vater
m
mit großer von bewegtheit und mit großem
respekt hat nicht nur die kirche sondern
die gesamte welt die nachricht von ihrer
entscheidung aufgenommen
auch das amt des bischofs von rom als
nachfolger des apostels petrus zu
verzichten
wir wären nicht ehrlich eure heiligkeit
wenn wir nicht zum ausdruck bringen
würden das wir heute abend eine stimmung
der traurigkeit in unseren herzen
herrschte denn in diesen jahren ihrer
amtszeit ihres pontifikates hat sich ein
fenster in der kirche und in der welt
geöffnet und hat die wahrheit und die
liebe gottes der liebe gottes einlass
gegeben und unser weg vor allen dingen
in den momenten in denen die wolken sich
im himmel versammeln hat uns russ
gespendet wir alle haben verstanden dass
gerade diese tiefe liebe eure heiligkeit
zu gott und zur kirche sie zu dieser
entscheidung gebracht hat und dadurch
gezeigt hat dass die stärke der demut
gemeinsam mit einer großen menge mut
jeden schritt ihres lebens gezeichnet
hat und auch jeden schritt auf dem weg
ihres amtes und das nicht nur durch das
beisammensein mit gott und im lichte des
wortes gottes nicht nur durch das
ständige gemeinsam
besteigen des berges mit gott diese
wahrheit verbreitet wird
die seminaristen der diözese von rom
haben eine ganz besondere aktion von
ihren ihnen gelernt denn dadurch dass
wir christen bin wissen wir dass die
zukunft uns gehört die zukunft nicht nur
uns sondern auch gott gehört die kirche
immer weiter die kirche erneuert sich
ständig und wird ständig neu geboren
die kirche muss der über festen
überzeugung sein dass die kirche nicht
uns gehört sondern gott und dass gott
sie erneuert nicht mehr
wir können mit wahrheit die worte des
evangeliums zitieren wir haben alles das
getan was wir tun mussten und haben uns
ganz in die hand gottes gegeben
auch mit dieser entscheidung sehr
schweren entscheidung bezeugen sie nicht
nur uns sondern auch dem gesamten volk
gottes großen respekt heute abend freuen
wir den herrn danken dafür dass die
ganze kirche unter der führung eure
heiligkeit diesen weg gehen die gesamte
kirche zurückgelegt hat und wir möchten
mit großer zuneigung mit innerer
bewegtheit und großem verständnis und
respekt
ihre leistung einen cent sollen als
treuer arbeiter im weinberg des herrn
wir wissen dass das wichtigste ist gott
zu den menschen zu bringen und die
menschen zu gott
vielen dank
[Applaus]
patienten yamada premiere
danke wir kehren zurück zum gebet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heilige vater erteilt nun den gläubigen
zum apostolischen segen so genannte
sektors etui meister cdu speed um com
funktion ist offiziell von und prämien
effektives repro missa misericordia kann
sich miryam chris zum daumen hoch
benedikt prozent ist patrice espiritu
santo
das sieht man
[Musik]
piening frieden geht hin ihr seid gesund
dank sei gott dem herrn
der abschließende große bild der
gottesmutter
[Applaus]
seine größte hemmnis chroniken sei
gegrüßt der engel
[Musik]
wurzeln der das heil entsprossen tür die
uns das heil das licht erschlossen
freudig jungfrau von der herde über
allen seligen haben
sei gegrüßt bis in die krone mit für uns
beide einem sony
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du bist petrus und auf diesen felsen
werde ich meine kirche bauen und die
mächte der unterwelt werden sie nicht
überwältigen
das bild ist
so sind geplant
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine damen und herren zu hause am
fernseher gerät das sind die letzten
bilder von papst benedikt bei einem
pontifikalgottesdienst die letzten
bilder im messgewand
herbst
[Musik]
mit bei mir im studio ist noch immer
ludwig ring eifel chefredakteur der
katholischen nachrichten agentur
wir sehen jetzt ein papst der das
stärkte und gelöster gelassener wirkt
als noch zu beginn der liturgie ja
unbedingt ich würde auch sagen es viel
gelöster jetzt als in dem moment wurde
kardinalstaatssekretär bertone eine
abschiedsrede gehalten hertha gabs einen
sehr ernsten und wirklich so als ob ihm
das auch gut tut dieser hindere applaus
der gläubigen im petersdom skater
minutenlangem stehenden applaus
wovon er ja sonst gar kein freund ist
diese
ganz außergewöhnlichen situation tut
deshalb gut
[Applaus]
der petersdom ist über und über gefüllt
mit menschen die ihn jetzt zum letzten
mal so sehen werden
es wird noch einmal zwei gelegenheiten
geben bevor er sich dann zurückzieht aus
dem aktiven leben und wahrscheinlich
auch nicht mehr so schnell zu sehen sein
wird
eine gelegenheit wird noch der angelus
sein
am fenster des plötzlichen palastes und
die andere dann am 27
februar die letzte generalaudienz von
papst benedikt dem sechzehnten
[Musik]
wenn wir den weg gelöst er wird ganz
kann es offenes lächeln
[Musik]
historische bilder des abschieds des
bischofs von rom ein letztes mal noch
nicht auf eigenen füßen aber dem
fahrbaren thron durch die bischofskirche
den weg mit dem papstpalast
[Musik]
hat er auch in seiner ansprache das
erwähnt dass er diesen gottesdienst als
den abschied seinen abschied
frauen geraten
[Musik]
[Applaus]